Did you get 18 5th and 3 5th? If you did, excellent work. This is a really tough
problem. Even if you didn't get this answer. If you got part of the solution
right, or some of the variables right, great work. I'm going to first solve this
problem using substitution. So, if you chose this method, stay with me. If you
tried elimination, fast forward until you see the word, elimination, here. Also
at any point if you find a correction to your work, pause the video and then try
and keep solving. Finding the types of mistakes you make is really important so
that we can improve on our math skills. Try and think about the mistake you made
and where you went wrong. Thinking about that mistake can prevent you from
making it in the future. I think it's easier to solve for x using this equation.
I just need to add y to both sides. So I have x equals 3 plus y, and remember I
could also write this as y plus 3. Addition is commutative. Now that I've solve
for x I can replace this x with the equivalent expression.3 plus y. So I have 3
times 3 plus y plus 2y equals 12, I distribute the positive 3 to get 9 plus 3y
plus 2y equals 12. 3y and 2y make positive 5y. And then I just carry down the
terms. So 9 plus 5y equals 12. I can subtract 9 from both sides, so 5y is equal
to 3. And finally I divide both sides by 5, so y equals 3 fifths. Now I can
substitute the value of y, which is 3 fifths, into the second equation. I chose
the second equation, because these coefficients were 1. It looked a little bit
more simple than the first equation. So I plus in the value of 3 5th for y. Then
I need to add 3 5th to both side to isolate x. So x is equal to 3 plus 3 5th. We
know we can write this as a mixed number. The mixed number is 3 and 3 fifths. We
have the whole number and then the fraction. Converting this to an improper
fraction we would have 18 fifths. This is some amazing math work for
substitution. If we use elimination I can multiply the second equation by a
positive 2. This will allow me to eliminate the y variable. You might have
chosen to multiply this equation by negative 3. That would've let you eliminate
the x variable. That's okay, that could work too. 2 times x is 2 x. 2 times
negative y is negative 2 y. And 2 times 3 is 6. So I get 5 x is equal to 18, and
the y's eliminate. To solve for x, we divide both sides by 5. So 1 x is equal to
18 5ths. We know that y should be 3 5ths, so let's see if we can find it, using
our x value. I'm going to use the second equation to find the value of y. I take
18 5ths, and plug it in for x. So I have 18 5ths, minus y, equals 3. Well I know
18 5ths is really 3 and 3 5ths. This is the mixed number that represents, or is
equal to, this improper fraction. 5 goes into 18 3 times and I have a remainder
of 3, or 3 5th. So I have to take away some number from 3 and 3 5th to get 3.
Well, this number has to be 3 5th. If I just think about it I know why it has to
be 3 5th. There's our solution.